CURRY FAKES, NOW DRIVES.
CURRY
AGAIN. REVIEW,.ark: THIS IS THEE
THE CALL ON THE FLOOR IS
>> Mark:TING JAMES.
OUT TO REAVES FOR  TO THE BASKE.
MAKES A TOUGH TWO. THE TRAP
AND TRY TO MAKE THE CONTEST
AND NOT FOUL,
HE HAD EVERYBODY TAKE EXTRA FREE
THROWS AFTER OFF.
JUSTST TIME-OUT, WARRIORS.
>> AND THEY ARE WAITING FOR
AND JAMYCHAL GREEN HAS THE
REBOUND.
AND A QUICK
TIME-OUT, GOLDEN
AND CURRY KNOCKS ITY WILL LOOK E
GOT IT OFF.
VIC LOMBARDI, NOT
HERE IS QUENTIN GRIMES, GRIMES,
E
WITH IT, BUT HE TO
BROWN. PUTS IT IN.
CAM THOMAS FROM WAY DOWNTOWN!
KNICKS ARE OUT OF T T CALL TIME.
THE KNICKS ARE OUT OF TIME-OUTS
BOTH OF WHICH PLAYED WELL TURNO
THOMAS FOR THREE.
HE GOT IT
GOT IT.
JIMMY BUTLER.IRVING.
TUCKER.
IRVING.FOURTH
QUARTER  FOR KYRIE IRVING.
WITH TWO.
A
1:15 TO 111.
NO FOUL. PHILLY.
HIGH SCREEN,
OUT ON THE SIDELINE AFTER THE
THE FREE-THROW LINE.
NIANG GETS IT IN FOR KORKMAZWAU
LAST GASP TO GET IT
AND WE  HA
FINISH WITH 15 POINTS IN HIS
FD
WITH SUNS BEING REPRESENTED.FF
FIRST GAME BACK IN OKLAHOMA SEC2
POINT
THE CLOCK.
PLPL
THE BUYOUT TO GET IT TO GORDON.
TURNS,
WHO IS A PERFECT FO THE
RUSSELL.
PAT BEV HAS GOT THE FLOATER.
>> Dave: ANDLE TO
KEEP KAT OUT OF THE MIDDLE OF
THE FLOOR A LOT OF THE NIGHT BU!
>> Dave: AND OUBRE IS GOING TOD
>> Brian: 33 SECON
DONCIC.
EIGHT SECONDS TO PLAY.
CLIPPERS WITH ONE TIME-OUT.
99- 97,
23 FOURTH QUARTER POINTS FOR